[Music]
don't waste my time another victory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
we're finished here let's go odds are
battle
[Music]
[Music]
come on really looks like I Fried's
first mate has a strange superstition
it's just a habit when it comes up tails
anyway what lid that coin come from I've
never seen a coin with a goddess on one
side and the Reaper on the other
strictly speaking that's not the Reaper
on the back it's an image of the demon
king dowse
where have I heard that name before
Martel the goddess and douse the demon
king the book of Ragnarok chapter 765
the Battle of Eid wrestle oh you're
awfully well-read the coin was dug up
from some ancient ruins in another land
they called the place Karlin long ago
it's made from soft ordinary gold but
they had some process to harden the
metal and make it resistant to scratches
wow that's a rather rare find then do
you like to read books Teresa's chamber
was full of them so I spent a lot of
time reading Ragnarok is a record of
battles from the age of myth I've read
it several times now anyway coins like
that are hard to come by where did you
get it
it's a long story never mind then so
were you deciding something with that
coin toss not anything I can talk about
yet oh I'm sorry for prying
[Music]
[Music]
we better be ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unarmed
hardly these are deadly weapons
[Music]
there's no guard do we just go in
wait this isn't what I expected
[Music]
there's a barrier over it
they changed the security you weren't
kidding were you
that's scorpion and this barrier well
part of your curse you'll be lucky if
that's the worst of it a direct assault
would be a bad idea what's the plan down
the cliff there should be an entrance
use during the fortresses construction
we'll check that
you did your research I had to didn't I